every day
like the one before
little town...
town
full of little people
waking up
*clap*
alright
on second <clearing>
and background
and play back
bonjour/ ta ta /good day /may wi / you call the made com/ some cheese /10 yards /one pound /excuse me /ill get the knife
there goes the baker with his tray like always
the same old bread and rolls to sell
Every morning just the same
since the morning that we came
To this poor provincial town.
Good Morning Belle!
G'morning Monsieur!
have you lost something again
I believe I have
10 yards /one pound /excuse me /ill get the knife
please let me through
this bread(the fish) is stail
that smell /madams mistaken
There must be more than this provincial life
good morning belle
ha.. wonderful book you got there
have you read it
it's the one's that play hard to get that are always the sweetest prey
thats what makes bell so appealing
she has not made a fool of her self just to gain my favor
what would you call that?
dignity?
it's outrageously attractive isn't it
*undecipherable audio*
what can I bring you?
a rose
like the one in the panting
you ask. for that every year
and every year you bring it
then I'll bring you another-one
*no sound*
afro  11 baker take 1
*clap*
*undecipherable audio*
Action
you are the wildest most gorgeous thing I have ever seen
nobody deserves you
but at least I know for children will be beautiful
am I caching you at a bad time
what is it lafo
trouble at the fountain
I told them that fountain will be trouble
oh well
its hero time
i'm not done with you yet
me nether
the only children you shod concern your self with are your own
I'm...
do you know what happens to /sministers/
in our village after there father's die
they beg for change in the street
madam Gaston  his little  wife
ERR no sir not me
I Guaranty it
where is papa
where is he
is every thing In hear alive
hello
whats your name
oh um... thats a hair brush
*snickers*
*Vocalizing*
do not be alarmed madam mussel
this is just you wardrobe
madam daga-
day robe a grate singer
a better sleeper
*vocalizing *
*music*
there's something-
hear we go.. rehearsing
aaaaaaand
*vocalizing*
hold me closer
*music ends*
oh beautiful ...beautiful
that was gorges
*music*
too much?
yep
*music*
*spits*
*Cheering*
they are coming finale checks everyone
toot sweet
no you don't
if the master finds out you violated his orders
and fet her
he would blame me
yes I will make sure of it
ooh!
the clock is ticking
the rose has fore petals left
which means you must tell her how you feel
you walked in and whoopsie daisy
*music*
*no sound*
*Camera clicks*
*mechanical humming*
*undecipherable audio*
*no audio*
ya
I believe this is yours
oh
thar she goes
*Background noise*
*no audio*
Action
are you not the least bit concerned
this casual might be haunted
don't lose your nerve lafou
Action
are you not the least bit consernd this casual
might be haunted
and... action
*Laughing*
*laughing*
CUT
*bell rings*
screaming /fog machine hissing
*music*
all right cam. up
*clap*
*music*
*drone blades wine*
*no sound*
thanks for watching